Hello, and welcome
to our presentation.
We hope you've had a
great conference so far.
So there's always a thing that
goes like this, all is well.
That starts with a good story.
Sorry I made that up.
Don't trust what I'm saying.
However, my colleague
and I thought
to bring a great
style, something
that resonates with us, our
experience and our talk.
So here's a quote from
one of our favorite books,
Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland.
And it goes like this, for,
you see, some out-of-the way
things had happened
lately that, Alice
had begun  to think that
very few things indeed
were really impossible.
So why are we
talking about this?
I want to put it into a
little bit of context.
Please take a moment and
watch the full on clip.
B2 and G2.
As you can see, this is
a voice control robotic arm
which is tracking to certain
locations on a chessboard
and do some tasks.
So what if we told you
the majority of this
was done in R?
My name is Eric Wanjau, and I'm
joined by my lovely colleague,
Ian Muchuri.
And today we talk about
a touch of R in robotics.
So you may be wondering, what
will make two guys do a project
in R, in particular robotics?
So here's the story.
One of the reasons that
led us into this adventure
was Hadley Wickham. So long
ago when Ian and I were
getting started in
R and doing some
of our electronic
engineering projects,
we started asking for the R to
grab some of these devices who
are dealing with and
also good recommendations
for some machine learning books.
So Hadley was nice, he was
really honest with us
and told us that at
that time we don't
know anything about
Raspberry Pi or Arduino
or some of these devices, but
he gave us a good starting
point in machine learning.
So then that's it for
Hadley.
And with this response
it got us thinking.
So we are like, if Hadley
doesn't know about this
and we figured it out and
shared it with the R community.
Then that would be a
really great impact
to the community in general.
So this is one of the reasons.
So the second reason
was that Ian and I
were involved in California
data science club, you know,
from our University didn't come
at the University of Technology
in Kenya.
And we get and we kept on
getting these questions.
So we see a lot of
ingenious things happening
with R in other domains,
such as sports or medicine
or pharma.
What can R do in electrical
electronics engineering?
There are two
reasons that really
made us think and, you
know, made us try out R
in what we love doing, and that
is electronics and robotics
and all that stuff.
So this is where
the story began.
Anyhow, back to R and robotics.
So in this talk,
we'll be presenting
a series of steps in which
we used R to achieve motion
of the robotic arm, as we saw.
And hopefully at
the end of it all,
you'll see how R
played a pivotal role
in the success of this project.
So Ian, to move a simple robotic
arm what do we actually need?
Yeah to move a
simple robotic arm,
the first thing
that you need to do
is actually set up
your robotic arm,
which basically means
setting up the hardware
that you're going to be using.
And the beauty about this
is that the pieces already
come precut.
All you have to do is
actually remove the pieces
and actually assemble
them together.
And once you do this, you can
it only takes about 30 minutes
to an hour.
And with the right enthusiasm,
I can actually do this.
And you're already done with the
first step, which is actually
setting up the manipulator.
So after you're
done with the setup,
after you're done
with the hardware,
you proceed to ask next
logical question becomes, what
are the manipulator inputs?
And just as a disclaimer.
In the course of
this talk, I will
be using the term
manipulator and robotic arm
to mean one and the same thing.
So don't get lost in that.
So you realize from the video
that Eric just showed us
that our manipulator
used voice as an input.
So how do we
achieve this in R?
So the first thing that we did
is actually record the voice
using audio package in R, whereby
we recorded the command B2
and G2.
Once we have our voice
input, we transcribed
this using Azure, Azure
Cognitive Services,
and transcribed the
voice input into text
using httr package and
jsonlite package,
I'm sure some of you
have familiar with that
after doing that,
the transcription
and getting the output.
We proceeded next to do some
assertions to ensure
that indeed the format
that results that we got
from Azure is actually
correct, because you realize
in some cases, there are some
errors and after doing this
we extracted the
characters from the text
whereby B2 was the
initial position and G2
was the final position.
So to make the
API call to Azure, we
use the sample code shown
in the slide whereby all you
needed to do is actually
define our subscription key,
which you actually
got from Azure.
Once we set up our
cognitive services
on the platform. Define
the content type, which
was audio file, the flavor of
English that you are using,
which was US English, upload
our recorded audio,
got the transcript,
the transcript data
using POST request to the API.
And then from this we actually
pulled the initial position
and the final position
in text format.
So just to recap, what's the
state of data at this point?
So at this point we had
our voice input, B2 and G2.
Run it through
Azure, and then we
got a string equivalent
of a string which
is B2 and G2 representing
a specific chess pose,
just chess pose actually,
which is B2 and G2,
which is the final position.
So after, after deriving the
string, the next bit becomes,
you know, defining the workspace
whereby the manipulator will
be working on.
And to answer this, we ask
ourselves the question,
where is the manipulator
actually going?
And I believe,
Eric, are you going
to tell us where was
the manipulator going?
To answer your question, Yeah.
What we need to do is to
assign a spatial coordinate
to the chessboard location
that we just obtained
from the transcription.
So how did we approach this?
So we started first started by
creating a virtual board in R
using ggplot.
Probably a lot of you have used this
to create some elegant graphics
in R. Once we did
this, we extracted
the central pixel
location and then
the next point was
translating the pixel location
to actual real world board
coordinates in centimeters.
So and to do this, we use
the scales package in R.
So what did we approach
to use this output?
So we figured out that different
boards come in different flavors
and dimensions.
So we needed a virtual
board that is static.
And then depending on the
dimensions of the chessboard,
one can then translate the pixel
location to actual real world
location depending on the
dimensions of his or her board.
So at this point, we can
combine everything and put it
in a good old table where we
have the position of, of,
of this current box
on the chessboard.
And most importantly,
the x and y-coordinates
are in centimeters
of what that would
represent a location of a
chess piece on a chessboard.
So let's wrap this up.
So we started with speech.
And then we got a transcription.
And then for each
start and end point,
we now have x and
y-coordinate x, y and z,
coordinate that represent
the position of a chess piece
on a chessboard.
So for instance, B2 can
be represented by 6 centimeter
the X, 15 centimeters on
the y, and 3.5 on the z.
So 3.5 is just at the
height of the chess
piece that will be moving
around on the chessboard.
So the next logical
question now becomes,
how will the
manipulator get there?
Yeah so to answer this
question, just take a moment
and just observe the
video that's playing.
And you realize from
the video that there
are these three blue
things that have
some cables connected to them.
Those are actually
motors and they
are responsible for
the manipulator motion.
And in this case,
we had three motors
which were controlling motion.
And yeah, and really the
motor, the motion of a motor
is actually
rotational in nature.
And from Eric's point, we
now have our coordinates
in terms of x, y and z.
So we have to find
a way of linking
the x, y, z, and
the motor angles,
converting x, y, z-coordinates
into the equivalent motor
angles.
And to do this, we
use a branch of math
called inverse kinematics.
I know it's a mouthful, but
just bear with us for a second.
Yeah so at the moment, let's
treat inverse kinematics
as a black box.
So what inverse
kinematics does, does
in a nutshell is it
takes x, y, z inputs,
converts them into
the equivalent angles.
Therefore, we have our
x, y, z-coordinates,
which are actually converted
into motor angles that
can now move the manipulator.
And just to give you a feel of
what inverse kinematics is all
about, I give you some
fare warning, there's
some math ahead.
So just hold on tight and
bear with us.
And yeah, so to do
inverse kinematics,
it's actually based on
trigonometric functions which
are, you know, the
things that most of us
learned in elementary
and just need
to brush up a little bit on.
Yeah and the beauty about this
is that most robotic arms,
once you buy the kit, it
comes with the instructions
for inverse kinematics.
Most probably people,
they are people
there are people out there
whereby people have already
done the inverse kinematics.
So you don't really have to the
deep stuff about these things.
So you just need a
high level of, of, you
just use the code that is
being used by other people.
Yeah and in case
it's not the case,
it's not provided, you can
actually come up with your own.
And this is a sample of
what we actually did.
And as you can see, we
use the basic, you know,
tangent, sine and
cosine functions
that we learned in elementary.
So all you need to do is
actually is actually, you know,
brush up on those
skills and then, yeah,
we'll probably give a
more detailed approach
as to how we came up with
these equations in our repo.
Yeah, so just to
recap, what's the state
of data at this point?
So at this point we
got our audio file,
which was the input,
we transcribed it
and got the string
B2 and G2,
which we actually
transpose the B2 and G2
into the real world, x, y,
z-coordinates that represented,
you know, just chess piece
locations of the chessboard
and using inverse
kinematics were
able to translate the x, y,
z into the equivalent motor
angles.
And you realize
that since we have
three motors, the
way we identify
which is which motor is
actually by using the string.
So a letter A corresponded
to the first motor,
letter B to the second motor,
letter C to the third motor.
So 112A meant 112
degrees to motor A,
126B meant 126 degrees to
motor B, 107C meant 170
degrees to motor C rather.
And finally, go to the fun
part, which is actually
moving the robotic arm.
So Eric, how did we
move the manipulator
to the desired positions?
So let's answer Ian's question.
At this point, we
have everything
that we need to move the chess
pieces on the chessboard.
So know that we know the
location of the chess pieces
and the angles required
to move the manipulator
to that position.
So we now need to find a way of
linking R and the manipulator
and how to do this.
So this is architecture
that we used where R is
doing all the heavy
lifting and finally
sending a string of data
that Ian just described.
And at the middle we have
an electrode device known
as a microcontroller
and a microcontroller
you can think of it as
an electrical device.
So you can connect
multiple peripherals
such as motors or LEDs
or speakers or sensors,
then define some
instructions on how
to send electrical signals to
manipulate those peripherals
that is connected to it.
In our case, these are motors,
we want the motors
to rotate to some given angles.
So that was the work of
the microcontroller, which
in our case was Arduino just
receive a string of data
and then send a signal
to each respective motor.
Then the motors would rotate
and bring the manipulator
to the desired to
the desired position.
So once we had this figured out,
the next logical thing was not
to ask ourselves, how
do we send data from R
to the microcontroller? At
this point when we realized
that most
microcontrollers can be
programmed via serial interface.
So a serial interface is a
communication interface
in which data can be sent
and received sequentially.
So with this, we
just had we just
had to figure out how to
set up a serial interface in R.
And then a microcontroller
can read that serial interface
and send the electro
signal to move our motors
and bring the manipulator
to the desired position.
So how do we set up a
serial interface in R?
You know, surprisingly enough
there is already a package
that helps us to do this.
So the package known
as package serial.
So with serial just
requires the serial package,
just require some few parameters
to set up the serial interface.
And some of these parameters
are input parameters.
And our arguments for that
is the port, the port number.
So this is the
USB port which you
connect the, the
microcontroller to, to your PC.
The next thing, the next
argument is the boundary.
So this is the rate at which
you send and receive data,
which was 9600 bits per second.
So we want a speed
that is just right.
Not too fast, not too slow.
And the next parameters
are there by default
and they and they just help
in structuring how data
is sent to the serial interface.
For instance, do you want a
new line appended at each,
at each instance of the data?
Yes. What what, what
hot, hot character
do you want to append after
each new line carriage return?
So this just
describes how to send
how to structure data that is
sent to the serial interface.
And after you've done, how to
set up the serial interface,
you now write data to it.
And to write data to it,
we just combined the strings
of angles into our vector.
Then we use purrr walk
to write each,
each element of the
vector to the serial,
to the serial connection.
So once the data is on
a serial connection,
now it's time for
the microcontroller
to read that data
and do its thing.
So these are the
instructions that we
put on the
microcontroller whereby
it checks whether data is
available on the serial, reads
data from the serial
processing just to extract
the numeric part of the string.
And then depending on
the case, say A, B or C,
it writes that value,
you know, that integer
to the respective motor
associated with the string.
For instance, if
it sees A it knows
I'm sending an angle to motor
A. B sends an angle to motor B.
And at this point,
we have achieved
the basis of our whole project.
You know, we started from
transcribing, transcribing data
all the way to
knowing the angles
to which to move the robotic
arm and finally moving
our robotic arm using the
help of a microcontroller.
So with this, you
can set up some
I would say some more complex
tasks, such as achieving
a capture move in, using
arm, using our manipulator
like we're going to see
in the following clip.
G3 and B2 capture.
Perfect! So this basically
using all that information
that we have, you know,
that we have described
and just adding some
layers of complexity to it.
And at this point, we hope
you have successfully showed
you some touch of R in robotics.
So everything has some
pros and cons right, Ian?
Yeah, definitely.
Everything has its
own pros and cons.
And in the course
of this project,
we realized that there
are some key areas
that we wanted to highlight
that R really excelled.
And one of the key areas
that we saw that R excelled
was when it came to
data manipulation.
It was easier to do
data manipulation with R
because I realized
that R is actually
optimized for such tasks.
And also we realized in
the course of the projects
that a big chunk of robotics
is actually a data problem
and it can also easily be solved
in R. Therefore it became quite
easy using R and also R is
actually less computationally
expensive as compared to
what we've used before,
which was Matlab.
It's the software that actually
is used by guys in our field,
specifically the
guys doing research.
And the reason why we say
this is because we realized
with Matlab, once you put it up,
it loads all the packages that
come with Matlab, but you
realize with R, you only
load the packages that you need.
Therefore it becomes
a bit light on the PC
and it becomes easier to use.
And also R is open source
therefore meaning anybody
can actually reproduce what
you did once they have access
to the R and actually
it becomes easier
to actually do this without
having so much of resources.
So the issues.
The main issues that
we face using and using
R was that serial
communication, which Eric just
highlighted was a bit slower.
Yeah and we thought
that maybe this
could be an issue with a
package and it's something
that we are willing
to look at in future
and maybe offer
some suggestions.
And also the audio package
that you use to record audio
was a bit it wasn't up to date
because each and every time
after recording an audio, an
audio and an audio objects,
rather we had to restart R so
that you can actually record
another audio object,
meaning you can't do two
consecutive inputs without first
necessarily having to restart
it, which was a bit annoying and
you know, it was a bit hectic.
So what's next?
Because, you know, like what?
What next?
Which is our next adventure?
So we plan on adding
and contributing
R packages, specifically
packages geared
towards the engineering field
because we believe that given
our background, this is
something that can actually
add to the community and
actually build the community,
and also speaking
about communities,
we also want to build
R communities
specifically in
engineering, such as what we
have in medicine, R in pharma.
You want to also have community
of R, that of R users
that are actually in
the engineering field.
And also because
we are adventurous,
we hope that we will explore
other unexpected uses of R
and once we give, you
are able to get something
you'll share with everyone.
Yeah and Eric, I
don't know if there's
anything else that I left out.
Not much, Ian.
Everything was really well said.
And Thanks a lot for that.
So hoping that we get to
the next adventure soon.
So but anyhow, we really
wanted to wrap everything up,
but just noting that a
lot of the majority did,
we did using packages that
are already in the R ecosystem.
We thought by when
we were starting
this you we had to
reinvent some tools,
but there was no need for that.
Everything we used
was everything
that has already been
built and we just
had to modify it to our needs.
So we hope we really
present a good case
of an unexpected using
R, and mostly we
hope that we've
inspired one, two to try out
R in their domain or R or in
some fun activities they have,
you know, just using
R everywhere and anywhere.
So anyhow, time to wrap up.
So we hope to wrap
up with, you know,
let's see a quote from
Alice in Wonderland
like we did from the beginning.
But we have not find one that's
really befitting to our story.
So we made one up.
So if there's ever
a story written about Eric and me,
I hope it goes like this,
For you see, so many out-of-the-way
things had happened lately,
that Eric and Ian had
begun to think that
very few things indeed
were really imparsible.
And an emphasis
the R in imparsible.
So thank you so much
for listening to us.
Please do have a
good conference ahead
and take care of yourselves.
So talk soon and bye bye.